[Music]
let's go to cassie in kansas city hey
cassie what's going on
hi dr dalone thank you so much for
taking my call i watch all your videos
and you have helped me in many many
areas i appreciate that those could be
some uh
i'm not very good at this so thanks for
being one of the few people that watch
those videos how can i help you what's
going on okay so um
my long-term marriage is neurodiverse
um which we just found out a few years
ago
a relationship has really passed a stage
of resentment which i know
you say once you get there
it's harder to come back yeah yeah so we
have basically just been really good
roommates for a while okay um when you
say neurodiverse do you have a
does he have personality disorders do
you have autism or a traumatic brain
injury what's he got um so he is on the
uh on the spectrum okay how where
i i mean if
you'll have to forgive me because i
don't i'm not familiar with the
terminology a time but um
the outdated thing but that's what we
were told at the time cool yeah
hey everybody's doing the best they can
with the tools they got so it's you're
not gonna hear me hating on you um so
he's high functioning at this point
absolutely okay all right so um you
found this out when a couple years ago
yes it's been about four or five years
ago
and what steps has have you all taken
together has he taken
um
what's the last four or five years been
like uh
they
i can't say they've been easy
um they have been
it was rough before that and
if i had to be honest i would say that
the diagnosis was almost
more disheartening than it was
encouraging
because
because beforehand anything that
[Music]
hurt my feelings or i didn't understand
i could blame it on
uh his childhood um on the aces score
he's a six he didn't have a great one
yep um
he was never helped as a kid i've never
seen his parents have him to this day
sure
so i thought i could blame it on the
fact that he just didn't know better
and
i could
eventually teach him
what i needed
but the reality is a lot of those things
are
because of because of
his asperger's because
of the autism um and i didn't know that
until i could read it i could read
articles and
and then it would just smack me in the
face oh my gosh this is
somebody else knows exactly how i've
been feeling
but but
i know you're hurting can i be super
honest with you though and i'm not
trying to be mean okay no that's okay
trying to be direct um
i need it
the way you just phrased that or the way
i heard it was
i would rather
him
be ignorant
or
unwilling
than to have some biological challenges
and the idea that you cannot teach
somebody with who's a high functioning
autistic adult
ways that they can love you better is
inaccurate
absolutely totally you can
and so whether it's childhood trauma
whether it is just knuckle-headed [ __ ]
idiot dude who's just like no i don't
know what
or
somebody with um
some neurological challenges that may
not ever
connect with your feelings but knows
that these feelings are real and that
you are having them and this is the way
that i can best love her in these
moments
man
there's there's choice and chance all
across that thing so what i hear you
saying is after the last four or five
years
have you given up on him or has he said
i'm not trying
no absolutely not
i would say at the beginning
[Music]
i
i guess i should have said a pleasant
spot with that's how i feel now looking
back at it at the time i was like okay
if i can just explain these things in a
different way um
something may click
and
now i know if you say something hurtful
then it's really not
i need to not take it so personally and
then explain to you why that hurts my
feelings yes um
and then maybe it won't happen again or
i can explain to you what i need
um and
to be 100 honest i feel like that's
that's hard to do
that's hard to have to tell somebody how
to love you it is it's hard yeah
it's real hard and you want to be able
to
you want to be able to walk home from
work and walk in the door and they look
across the room and the music swells and
he sees you
and he knows what you need right i'm
being totally honest right totally
honest and that's not something like
that in just
non-typical neurological families that's
in every marriage i've ever heard in my
life right
um
so but i
it is painful and it's exhausting and it
feels lonely and hollow right
i couldn't have put it in better words
that's for sure how i felt for a very
long time okay so
do you want to stay married
you sound like you're done
i feel like i wouldn't be calling you if
i was done maybe okay um i feel like
i'm just
i'm just
desperate because i feel
like i know we can do this
i know we can do this and i
just don't have the tools to do it and
the people that i reach out to the we've
gone to marriage therapy um we're going
to marriage counseling um he's he's seen
a therapist on his own um
we have just had bad luck after bad luck
as far as that's concerned to where
they're either
um
it's not really their forte like they
come at our marriage with a neurotypical
mindset and that's not helpful
or um one in particular that we went to
see um told me that i just needed to
learn how to live in an autistic world
and that didn't ring true to my heart
either because the truth is this isn't
uh you know regular life isn't going to
change for him
and i don't mind um
i that sounds horrible
no it doesn't matter anyway here's the
thing i um
i guess i would refute that
and there can be some autism specialists
that um
can write in i'd love to i'd love to be
shown i'm wrong here
my experience which is uh you know
admittedly limited
is
it is equally lonely and hollow living
inside an autistic mind
and while they may not be able to
um
experience some of the same experiences
that a neurotypical person might i don't
even know what that means anymore but
what i know what you might feel right
they do they can experience
the joy the pleasure of knowing that
they are caring for somebody in a way
that that person has asked to be cared
for
i've seen it
and it's really remarkable
and i've also worked with folks who have
to remember oh this is when i make that
smile on my face
because that brings joy to the people
around me and this is when i raise my
eyebrows and say wow
but that in and of itself is an
expression that attempt that try that
leaning into
is such a um
it's such a powerful expression of love
even though it looks different does that
make sense
absolutely
and so
i do get 100
the hollywood version of this is over
right and it is it can be so lonely and
you say all the time you know have a
funeral for it
believe me i have i i was already there
i was there i started listening to you a
year ago
you know
that
i'm not i'm never going to have the
husband who writes me a love song or
accept yourself because that's not my
husband except
if you said
once a month i need you to write me a
love poem
and you are allowed to use somebody
else's lyrics
and then you would know
how non-intuitive that is how hard that
is what a challenge that will be
and he'll do it anyway
and what you're gonna have to do is
decide just because it's on his calendar
it doesn't mean less
and just because
he doesn't have long hair like fabio and
he's holding i can't believe it's not
butter and he's not riding a dragon or
whatever that it's still romantic even
though it looks different does that make
sense
it a hundred percent make sense and so
it's it's coming to and here's the thing
in
completely neurotypical couples
the idea of putting sex on a calendar
is always this like everyone feels like
well if we have to put on the calendar
then we should even be married and i
just call bull crap on that if we have
to plan dates they're not really dates
it's stupid yes they are does that make
sense
none of this looks like hollywood right
and so
oh no
it has never it has never looked like
holidays
it
and i don't have dreams of it looking
like hollywood oh i know i know right
now i'm speaking to everybody right
you're way past that i know i know
you're way way past that here so
have you sat down and you may have done
this
have you sat down and said every sunday
night
that will be our planning for the week
and we're going to plan our budget we're
going to plan our calendar
and we're going to plan my needs
because here's what i'm telling you if
every married couple on planet earth did
this the world would look very different
in a positive direction
if everybody sat down and said here's
what i need right now here's what i need
this week here's the hands motion i need
when i am saying something that's
hurting your feelings my wife and i have
had these conversations recently
because she's going through some shifts
that are setting some of my old alarms
off in a way we've been together for 25
years and i i didn't know we're there
and i had to say when i start responding
like this i need you to just reach your
arm out and then i'll know
and she's like got it and she's done it
twice it's been amazing right but it's
that lo and it feels so on jack and rose
right like i just we're supposed we saw
each other in the titanic it's just
supposed to be this is not how it's
working so if you had that conversation
would he love you enough to lean into it
we have had many of those conversations
um
for an example
our intimacy there just isn't any
anymore okay but
have you said i need sex three times a
week and i need it like this i need
dress up night this night i need music
night this night i need old boring
married sex on this night have you done
that
i have said
i need
10 minutes
of your undivided attention every night
after the kids go to bed okay
and what is that undivided attention is
amorphous for me
so
have you said i need 10 minutes of you
holding my hand and i want you to take
off your shirt and i just want to hug
you skin-to-skin
or i want you just to listen to me
chit-chat
like what have you been specific
and the reason i'm saying that is is
that i've had to do that in my own
marriage
every couple i work with has to end up
there in their own marriages and i'm
trying to tell you you're not crazy
but it is gonna take a heightened level
of and i'm not trying to say that your
marriage is typical it's not you've got
some deep challenges in this thing
but you're gonna have to get that
specific and that specificity
can become really erotic
and really fun and really directive does
that make sense
it does
am i crazy
you're not crazy i for me i thought uh i
mean for months i asked for i just need
a deeper connection with i just want to
me and you to have a relationship again
i just want to like check in how are you
doing how am i doing how you feeling
what's going on in your world
i want to i want to i i wanted that and
and then that didn't work out very well
so then it got to just come and let's
talk for 10 minutes
and apparently and what i hear you
saying is i need to be even more
specific than give me 10 minutes of your
time each night i when you say that to
me as a husband i don't know what that
means
like i i i is that chit chat time do you
want us to go french kiss for a while do
you want me just to sit there and nod
you want me to fix i i don't know what
that means i think there's a scenario
here
where you could have a blast
coming up with a
weekly marriage worksheet
that your autistic husband is going to
check off how is your day today did you
have mostly positive
things happen at work did you have
negative things happen at work what made
it what made you sad what made you
experience joy and y'all check this
worksheet off together is that
ridiculous yes is that intimate yes
and so what i'm telling you is
there and that's why i asked are you
done because what it feels like is
that level of intentionality
that can how long have y'all been
married
16 years there you go every 16 year old
marriage i know is in this boat not as
deep as yours yours is unique hear me
say that
but every 16 year old marriage i know of
starts speaking in i just miss the old
us
or we just aren't having sex like we
used to or the kids are and it becomes
this speaking in generalities in these
big grandiose pictures
and everybody starts you've heard me say
this over and over i'll say it again
we think in pictures but we
but we speak in words
and so when you say i just need 10
minutes of your undivided attention
he has a picture in his head of what
that looks like
and you do too and you're missing each
other because your pictures are
different you're both using the same
words and he thinks he's doing right
or when you say
i need sex this week he says great and
his picture is six minutes and we're
done and your picture is i just need
some glass of wine and the music i need
the kids to disappear and i need it to
be like we were dating right does that
make sense
absolutely so it's that level of oh it's
not less romantic and in fact if you can
get into the head part of this the
desire and the eroticism part of this
and let your head go crazy about the guy
that you love
it can be real fun
and you can begin to practice desire
with specificity
and you can practice desire with
explicit here's what i need
here is what connection looks like and i
haven't met i
i haven't again admittedly i haven't
worked with a ton of folks with autism
but the high functioning adult autistic
folks that i've had a chance to to work
with
love
that level of specificity and the guys
i've been around the men and women i'm
around
are all in
right because they want so badly to
connect
and i would really
recommend you give that a shot high
levels of specificity say beginning this
week we have a sunday night meeting you
and me no kids they're off whatever
whatever and we're gonna plan the week
we're gonna plan love we're gonna plan
budget we're gonna plan
uh i don't know calendars and we're
gonna start from there and then start
being as
specific as possible and if you can
co-create a worksheet together
co-create the calendar together and say
these two nights are sex nights
this night is hugging night
and i want 30 minutes of hugging and i
want you to wear these clothes
yeah i know it's different it's never
been in a hollywood maybe it has i don't
know
and here's the other thing
he can learn forgiveness and grace and
he can learn not record keeping of all
your faults which i know that's can be a
challenge in these in these type of
relationships he can practice
self-awareness
he can practice being quiet practice
asking kind questions so maybe on a
worksheet you say ask me three questions
about my day
and again you're teaching and is that
your job no but is that gonna help bring
you all together yes
he can learn to be gentle with the truth
right he can and and when i say that
he can say
is that what you're wearing versus a
very direct ugly comment about your
right all those things
starts with you being really intentional
and here's what i want to tell you if
you feel you started this call saying
man
we've been a resentment a long time
the way out of resentment
is an all-in i'm doubling down with
intentionality that's the only way out
i'm going to be hyper hyper hyper
intentional
and i think you can do it so here's what
i want you to do i want you to have this
meeting with him and let him speak into
it
um i don't know a lot of people who once
they say hey let's put this stuff on the
calendar that would that want to push
back
hopefully he wants to be all in too
i want you to have this meeting and then
once you write me back let me know how
that meeting went and we'll be thinking
about you along the way
get two or three or four sunday nights
into this deal
and let me know if things have changed
because my god tells me it can my god
tells me you can
but it does mean you're gonna have to be
super specific and you may need to go
see somebody to talk about your
loneliness your anger your
oh this looks so different but you said
you've already had the the funerals for
what was and now it's time to plan for
what could be
and i know i'm high optimistic on this
one i am i am i am i am
double down on intentionally specificity
let's see what happens next